One way to convince people something is hard is to post a challenge,
provide some motivation, and see if anyone can solve it.
This particular challenge was posted in Martin Gardner's Scientific American column
in an article that he wrote in August 1977
that was introducing RSA to a wide audience.
The technical paper on RSA was published shortly after that in 1978.
As part of this article, he asked for Ron Rivest to come up with a challenge.
This was the challenge that was published in this article.
Given a public key and an e--and here we have n as a 129-digit number--
and the intercepted cipher text, figure out what the message was.
That can be done by factoring n.
Ron Rivest estimated that factoring n would take about 40 quadrillion years.
It turns out this was a little bit off.
The actual time was 17--without the quadrillion--years.
It was shown by a team lead by Derek Atkins in 1994
that these two numbers multiplied together to produce the n in the challenge.
For the quiz, the question is what does this mean--
the fact that Derek Atkins and his team were able to break n into these two factors.
This is kind of a silly quiz, but I hope you'll think about it anyway.
Some of the answers are more serious than others.
It could mean that RSA is fundamentally broken.
It could mean that the magic words are "squeamish ossifrage."
It could mean that RSA keys need to be longer than 129 for good security.
Or it could mean that time flies when you're factoring,